buenas tardes esta aprobación significa
un segundo pedido por parte del
legislativo de un proceso de vacancia
presidencial contra el presidente de
pedro casi o las razones que están
señalando los legisladores es que el
mandatario habría incurrido en
contradicciones y mentiras ante las
investigaciones que está realizando la
fiscalía también se señala que ha habido
irregularidades en el ascenso altos
oficiales de la fiscalía de la policía y
que el mandatario también habría estado
incurrido en estas anomalías otro
detalle que también señalan los
legisladores es que el mandatario habría
nombrado a personajes cuestionados al
cargo del ministro de estado y también
reuniones clandestinas que se habrían
realizado con proveedores parlamentos va
a tratar de definir si como inicialmente
habían planteado que está el proceso de
vacancia se realice el 28 de marzo que
es el día lunes o se adelante al viernes
18 por lo pronto pedro casi o asistir
mañana a las 17 horas al parlamento para
emitir un mensaje a los peruanos algunos
suspicaces señalan que el mandatario o
tratará de influenciar la decisión de
los congresistas y tratar de que no se
llegue a los 87 votos que se requieren
para mover el moverlo del cargo